- Legitimate question:
Whenever I eat apples
or potato products, I sweat a little bit
and my nipples get hard.
For a second I thought this was gonna
be a very medical question
and then it just took a turn.
(dance music)
This is one of my favorite segments I do,
but before we start reading
and responding to your comments,
I want to ask you a couple of questions.
I've seen a few comments
of people requesting
me to start selling merch.
I wanna do that if
that's what you're into.
I can come up with some
pretty funny mug slogans,
t-shirt slogans,
I can give you a shirt
that almost looks like
the scrubs with my logo on it,
donate some of the proceedings
to Limitless Tomorrow
or some of the other
foundations I work with.
And the second thing
that I've seen is people
asking if I have a PO box
so they can send questions and letters.
I've already had some
letters sent to my hospital,
I just posted on Instagram,
it's a really cute drawing
by an 11 year old girl
that was just adorable.
So if you want one of those
or you want two of those,
or you like none of those,
leave it down below in the comments,
and I hope you enjoy
this week's responding
to comments video.
Let's get started, pew woop!
Whenever I eat apples or potato products,
I sweat a little bit
and my nipples get hard.
Why is that?
I love your channel.
Officer moose, awesome username.
Your nipples get hard from
eating apples or potato products?
There's a condition known
as oral allergy syndrome
which is not exactly
what you're describing
but basically what it
is is your mouth tingles
and it feels like you're
having a little bit
of allergic reaction when you eat foods
with certain triggering proteins.
Again that can happen
with apples, bananas,
but it has nothing to do with
your nipples getting hard.
Officer moose, I don't know if
you're turned on by potatoes.
As they say, whatever floats your boat,
I'm not here to judge.
Would you be willing to do
a video on the word quiet
in the ER.
I have heard there is a secret rule,
never say for example quiet day so far.
Chaos King, you're absolutely right.
You never wanna say that
it's been a quiet day,
you never wanna say
it's been a quiet call.
For some reason,
every time you say that it's been quiet,
and you're grateful for it,
you suddenly get a lot of admissions,
emergency situations, rapid responses,
code blues, and you start running around
like a chicken with its head (mumbles).
Now I'm not a superstitious guy,
I've said the word quiet,
and I've brushed people off who told me
I shouldn't have said it,
but I see why it exists.
Mirthe Van der Heide.
Hi I'm 13 years old and
recently I saw a video of
how you can grow a few inches per week
by doing stretches,
is this possible?
What you should focus on
to grow the tallest possible
is eating a healthy balanced diet,
making sure you get enough protein,
make sure you're eating
your veggies and fruits,
I know that sounds like
your grandma talking,
but it's true you need those minerals,
you need that ability to grow.
You need to get enough sleep,
because when you sleep
well you actually get
a lot of growth hormone release,
and when I say a lot I
mean the right amounts
so you're not hurting the amount
of growth hormone you're getting,
and then on top of that
you wanna make sure you're exercising.
When you exercise it boosts your hormones,
it boosts your growth hormone,
it makes you process food differently,
it makes your muscles grow,
and all of those things will contribute
to your physical appearance,
including your height.
Two girls were born to the same mother,
on the same day,
at the same time,
in the same month and year,
and yet they're not twins.
How can this be?
Okay give me a second Teresa.
Two girls, born to the same mother,
the eggs of a mother were
artificially inseminated
via in vitro fertilization,
and they were born by a surrogate,
so they were coming from the same mother,
even though they were
born in different women,
as different surrogates.
That's my medical answer to that question.
Is that the answer you think?
Is it normal to talk,
or in my case talk and sing in your sleep?
This is pretty cool Meg
I wonder if you're a good
singer in your sleep.
Actually talking in your
sleep has a medical term,
I'm gonna butcher how to pronounce it,
somniloquy I think is the
right way to pronounce it.
It is a normal behavior,
it's usually a short lived occurrence.
I wouldn't worry about it
unless causing a disruptance,
a disturbance,
to your sleep cycle.
If you occasionally chatter in your sleep,
it's not a big deal.
Actually what you should do is record it,
and play it back the next day.
I've actually heard of some
patients say some pretty
R-rated or X-rated stuff in their dreams,
so be careful you might
be spilling some secrets
to your partner.
Robert Mills, I know medical stuff,
like stethoscope, tongue depresser,
and suppository.
What do you know about it?
I hope everyone knows what
a tongue depresser is.
People hate those,
and I get it 'cause
when people put anything
into my mouth,
when people put any kind of
medical device into my mouth,
when people put a dental
mold into my mouth
it triggers my gag reflex
and I have a huge panic attack
I've said that before.
Yes Robert you know a
lot of medical words.
Doc I'm a disabled vet.
Thank you for your service,
Thank you for your sacrifice.
I've been gaining weight since I retired.
What kind of cardio stuff doesn't require
full use of the legs?
Oh Marion this is such a good question.
Immediately my head goes to swimming.
Whenever I think of low
impact exercise that is really
good for losing weight
I think of swimming.
I assume you can swim
without the use of your legs.
I think that there might be
some flotation aid devices
that you can use to help you swim
and allow your heart rate to go up.
I know you mentioned cardio to lose weight
and while high intensity
interval training is great
and you can do that
like I said by swimming
or playing some sports,
do some weight training.
I know weight training isn't
always related to weight loss
but actually if you put on
muscle on your upper body
'cause you can use your arms,
you can burn more calories
throughout the day
which will lead to more
sustained weight loss.
So people that just do cardio all day long
have trouble losing
weight when they plateau.
Michelle Squidy, hey Doc how's Roxy?
Haven't seen her in a
while hope she's good.
Michelle Roxy's amazing
I actually just had her
stay at my place for the last three weeks
because my dad went on vacation to Spain,
super jealous 'cause I didn't get to go.
Having Roxy there in my apartment is crazy
because they're just on top of each other
the whole time they love playing.
I try to share some stuff on Instagram.
If you're not following me
on Instagram you should be.
It's doctor spelled out dot Mike.
So definitely follow me
on there I put updates
on me Roxy and Bear all the time.
Is one sleeping position
healthier than others?
Me the general rule that
I give to my patients
is you should sleep in whatever position
you feel most comfortable.
Now if you experience pain
in this specific position,
you should change.
If you experience acid
reflex or post nasal drip,
there are ways to change
your sleeping position.
So if you ever feel like you're
not getting restful sleep
or you wake up feeling sore,
that's a good conversation
to have with your doctor.
Mr. Jason Hammer, hey
Doctor Mike can you tell us
what you think about weed?
Ah marijuana.
Marijuana marijuana marijuana,
hot topic in the press right now.
It's getting legalized
it seems like everywhere,
in New Jersey where I
practice you're able to
prescribe it for a certain
number of medical conditions.
In New York they're
thinking about legalizing it
for recreational use.
Is it as bad as something like alcohol?
Probably not, but do we
have firm research on that?
No not yet.
Not talking about marijuana
for medical usages.
I think marijuana for
medical usages should've been
researched decades ago,
and the fact that we haven't
is truly disappointing to me.
Now I'm talking about recreational use.
Now here's the difference.
When you drink alcohol,
because it affects so
many parts of your body,
gives you hangovers,
makes you throw up,
it functions itself as a deterrent,
so it limits how much you can drink
and how often you can drink.
When you smoke marijuana
or you eat an edible,
you can really do that
for a long period of time,
and you can do it multiple days in a row,
and it doesn't have much
of a deterrent other than
probably I would say smell,
because a lot of people are turned off
by the smell of marijuana,
or at least many people that I know are.
So the fact that you
don't have this deterrent
that alcohol has can
really make you consume
a lot more marijuana than you can alcohol.
Also a lot of people self
medicate with marijuana.
They have some social anxieties
and instead of facing their goals,
instead of achieving and
becoming better people,
that they can become
happier with themselves,
they blunt that anxiety by
smoking or ingesting marijuana.
So do I think marijuana is
this horrible evil thing
that people have once said it once was
and I thought it was when I was younger
in fifth grade doing DARE
and all those other drug programs?
It probably isn't if it's destigmatized
and legalized it probably
won't be the gateway drug
that we once thought it would be.
I think it's on its way to get legalized,
but that doesn't mean that it's safe,
it doesn't mean that I
recommend people do it,
I do think it has serious
medical harms that do exist,
that we don't yet even know about
'cause it hasn't been studied properly.
My thoughts on marijuana,
should probably be legalized.
Before we start labeling something as evil
or amazing we should get
our research behind that.
So that's why I'm never going to tell you
marijuana is amazing or marijuana is awful
because I just don't have the
research to show otherwise.
The big danger with marijuana
is young people using it
and it can change the
chemistry of your brain
and change the development of it
so that's obviously a danger.
But we can regulate that,
we can control it.
There are some pros,
there's also some cons.
It's about balancing that
and getting your science in order
before making a decision.
I'm still looking at the science,
I'm not an expert,
I'm looking to improve,
so if you have some articles
you want me to take a look at
drop them down below in the comments
and I'll gladly read them to improve
my knowledge on the subject.
Why do you wear two watches?
Maria thank God you asked this question.
These are not two watches.
This is a watch, classical,
I love Zenith watches
I have a few of them.
I believe a gentleman
should always wear a watch.
This is a fitness tracker.
It's a Fitbit.
This is what I use to track my steps,
my heart rate,
I do some exercises on a Peloton bike,
so I'm not wearing two watches,
I wear a fitness tracker and a watch.
Genital herpes, there's
no way your username
is genital herpes that's crazy.
Hey Mike can you watch cells at work?
What's cells at work?
If you wanna link it into the comments
so I can see what it is I'm
totally down to watch it.
Mahnoor K.
I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right.
I'm trying my best.
Hey doc I was just wondering how did
that pew woop become a thing?
Keep doing it,
it's very cute.
So, how did this come about?
My videographer Dan
Owens was asking one time
for me to make a sound,
a transition type sound so he
can move on to another clip
or something like that,
and I didn't know what
to say so I said pew woop
and somehow pew woop
has now become the thing
that I do in my videos, pew woop.
And it just sounds like a cool sound.
If you guys wanna send me some DM's
of you guys going pew-woop,
I will repost them on my Instagram
'cause I just think it's cool, pew woop.
Thank you for submitting your comments.
Keep them coming,
and don't forget to click subscribe
and the little notification
bell which tells
YouTube that you're enjoying
this content and want more.
And as always stay happy and healthy.
The cow goes moo.
I'm gonna create merch with
a shirt that just has me
going like this that says pew-woop
and people are going to
come up to you on the street
and be like dude what are
you wearing on your shirt.
(dance music)